now the biggest winners at the local
elections were the Liberal Democrats and
we can talk now to the man of the moment
Lib Dem leader Sir Vince Cable who joins
us now from the forest thank you for
being on the program why do you think so
many people voted for the Lib Dems this
time out well I think a mixture of
reasons I think positive reasons we're
very committed to local government we we
do it well we campaigned intensively
over a period of months that was all
part of it it was disillusionment with
the government it was amongst people who
very strongly about remaining in the
European Union they got behind us too so
it was a mixture of reasons we did very
well in some of the plots of the South
of England that are very committed to
remain but we also did very well in
Somerset and Devon where they have a
different view and as you've just heard
we had big swings in and places like
Sunderland and Barnsley so it was it was
quite a deep process and it showed our
parties now fully recovered and a very
strong force in British politics it's
interesting actually say that the Lib
Dems appeared to do well in places where
there were strong remains votes but also
actually in places where the majority of
people voted to leave the EU I just
wonder if you think that means that some
of the vote at least was more of a
protest by really just a chance to give
her two main parties are kicking well
there is an element of that and I'm
perfectly realistic that that was one of
the factors at play but you know if you
take a place like Sunderland which was
very heavily leave it didn't just come
out of a protest but we worked there for
years we've got a team of dedicated
people who have gradually won their way
onto the council have done good work
there and have built on it and so yes
there was an element of a protest but
but there was much more than that it was
very much a positive vote for the
Liberal Democratic candidates and that
is going to carry forward I think into
the the European elections will have in
a couple of weeks time well let's talk
about the European election shall we
because you're gonna have a bit more
competition there aren't you for the
chance to get the two parties kicking
the brakes that party can be standing we
heard Nigel Faraj earlier on the
programme also change UK what would be a
good result for the Lib Dems well a good
result would be a significant
improvement on what we had last time
which was
yeah well indeed yes I mean one of the
problems of these European elections as
is you've implied the remain vote is
fragmented between three remain parties
I think that's unfortunate we would have
preferred to have worked together but
that's not happened so I think what what
is important for us is that the remain
voters in the country the people who
committed to remaining in the European
Union who want to press ahead with the
people's vote that those people get
behind us and we send them a very strong
message not just to the Conservatives
and Labour Party but also Dena Joel for
us that he's up against a very
formidable adversary here it's
interesting to hear you say that you
think it's unfortunate that the remain
parties weren't working closer together
change UK were pretty clear that they
didn't want to work too closely with the
Lib Dems perhaps thinking that you would
tarnish our image I just wonder if
they've had a change of heart went after
the local election results they'd only
been calling you up from change UK well
it's a bit late now the nominations have
been submitted and if that was the
calculation then it was clearly wrong
because you know we are a very positive
force but I said there's no point I
think just going over who said what to
whom and why we got where we are we are
now in on the ballot paper with the
other remain parties but our fire is
going to be directed at Nigel Farage
from the brexit parties and that the
terrible muddle and the panic which
we're now getting from their
conservative and Labour Party's that's
the opposition we're not aiming fire at
people who are in the same position as
we are there's been a bit of fire aimed
at you though I mean Chris Leslie for
example the changing K has said
previously the Lib Dems had fallen below
a critical mass that you have baggage
that you have a clear trust issue heidi
allen has said that her party was the
natural home with the remain alliance do
you think they're perhaps underestimated
how difficult it is to be one of the
smaller parties in UK politics
well those remarks are obviously
terribly wide of the mark but I you know
I like the people concerned I don't want
to get into a unnecessary spat with them
I think when these elections are over
we're gonna have to work together and
grow up and you know behaving in adult
politics I think that's what what the
public expects us to do rather than
exchanging snide comments you know we
are we've clearly done extremely well in
these elections we're back as a major
force I think that will carry over into
the European elections and then we'll
work with other people who share our
views on Europe and our values more
generally and really trying to change
British politics in a fundamental way
because I'm afraid the Tory Party and
the Labour Party have now become so
discredited people are looking for some
genuine alternative and we will be at
the core of that it's interesting isn't
it because it feels as if the last
general election was almost like
dominated by two party politics labour
in the Conservative Party got more than
80% of the vote between them do you
think what we're starting to see now is
the beginning of a splintering of that
dominance well I think I think in
retrospect it's very clear that 2017 was
an anomaly it was unusual it was
conducted in the aftermath of the
referendum it created I think a false
sense that the two-party system was
being reconstructed it's been gradually
dissolving over the last couple of
decades or so and I think it's now very
very clear that British politics is now
going to have to be remade I mean it's
clearly failing in all kind of ways and
then not just they mess around the
referendum but the fact that as a
country we're just not getting to grips
with really big challenges like housing
and how we deal with social care and
rising crime and the future of education
and we need parties that have a positive
vision can get themselves organized and
replace the rather moribund to put a
system that we have at the moment and
then I just want to ask you just to
close we often ask people to suggest
questions on social media for our gaps
and I couldn't resist asking you this
one from Barry HHH on Twitter he says
ask Vince if he's gutted he's jacking it
in now the Lib Dems did quite well in
the locals are you a little bit guttered
no I plans haven't changed I'm expecting
that my party will have a new leader
before the summer break I've always
intended that we should have an orderly
succession I'm
very happy to pass on the baton but I
will be leading the party through the
European election does very clear and if
the government fails a no-confidence
motion in the next few weeks as it could
well happen and we have a general
election then I'll be leading our party
into that - okay as servants capable
thank you very much for being on the
program today